hi we're here at the psycho booth here
at CES to check out a new idea at a CES
that doesn't have maybe a preponderance
of new concepts so these are some 5.1
channel gaming headphones can you tell
us how they work real simple we've taken
the 5.1 surround system that you have in
a theater three speakers in the front
two speakers in the back and your sub
woofer and we put them directly into the
headset and into the air cup so you're
getting full directionality there's no
filtration there's no lag there's no
latency we've got full 5.1 sound coming
through out so as you hear something
from the right side something from the
left side as the distance because it's
natural to follow down these waveguides
sound travels over the ear cup back up
through your getting directionality
always so there are drivers in this top
area to air got your three front drivers
you got your two rear drivers and then
you've got your subwoofers right in the
ear cup it's out and put those long
marathon gaming sessions we've got
vetted air cuffs oh cool yeah we've also
resolved an issue as far as how air or
sound wave travels over the year
typically you're getting these boom
boxes throwing sound interior what we've
done is we've actually taking these
horns located them inside oh yeah one in
the front one in the back that allows
the natural sound wave to follow over
the year allowing the ear to challenge
into so when guys are dropping down and
hearing gunshots coming around they can
actually drop stop and turn and get that
guy uh-huh nailed it that's why we won
the innovations award there you go I'm
so basically the psycho acoustics like
you're creating almost a little room in
there I mean this is basically like a
living room on your head or something
well what I love about you is just used
our sales pitch this is the perfect
perfect room in a headset ha okay I just
you've got a natural sweet spot instead
of having to sit in a theater see what
you've got is you got this perfect room
in a headset and so does this help
gamers I mean like are you more likely
to win I guess you would be if you can
hear somebody creeping up behind you
we've had some of the top gamers who I
won't mention their names come on in
and what they're getting is their kill
ratio is gone from a standard 2 to 1 2 3
2 1 or 4 to 1 because they're hearing
that gunshot instantly able to direction
that on a 45 and get that guy get that
guy so it's been phenomenal as far as
the feedback on what about for music
fans and movie movie people i mean you
know there isn't really a portable
surround sound format yet but is that
something that you're anticipating
absolutely i mean right now this is pc
gaming exclusive you know for the avid
full-time gamer but the opportunities
here are huge I mean I'll show here has
just about it I mean we've got the
capability to do xbox 360 ps3 all these
guys you're mean there's a certain
amount of adapting you have to do
manually to get it to work with your
traditional home theater system but on a
PC you can run any petty program off of
that I guess I guess that leaves the
question of how much is it going to cost
and when are people going to be able to
check it out in stores great question
299 retail available on the web now
we're going to be available to ship q2
or early spring of 2009 so it's 300
bucks but for that kill ratio I guess
that that's easily worth it for a lot of
people it looks good it's a hot piece
this is this is a piece that is
different to anything that's out there
it's one of the few innovations of this
show that people are really driven de
wardes and so for that reason we've got
a technology that nobody else has done
nobody else can reproduce so we've got
something very unique okay i'm going to
try out these psycho surround sound
headphones and see how they sound
I'm definitely hearing a lot of gunfire
coming from all different angles here it
is actually fairly convincing very nice
well the mission failed but the
headphones did I think it's very
convincing it's very nice surround sound
nice work